okay what am I excited about today what
I'm excited about this week is Bill
Gross and Jeff Gundlach they change the
dialogue on what we see in Germany but
did the German you'll go up to the price
go down of the german 10-year bond did
that happen because of those two big
hitters and bonds or did it happen for
other reasons I will suggest it happened
for other reasons let's go in with a
strong euro and look at the German a
tenure and what I've done here is
different to accentuate the distortion
this is a log chart which shows
percentage change so Down Goes the yield
on the german 10-year this is Draghi QE
we get down almost a 0% and you begin to
see the move back to the yellow 200-day
moving average and the one percent yield
ear and the headline is in a breath in a
matter of days we've made back well over
fifty percent of the move back to those
two benchmarks on the german 10-year
yield so the summary is price matters
just as much as yield and yeah the yield
can go up a little bit of teeny bit but
that can be a huge price move when
you're under one percent so what am I
excited about Oh Bill Gross Jeff
Gundlach it particularly what's going on
in a better hero